[Music]
[Applause]
luna the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin if you're just getting into
crypto it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the leia
hill pen show we are live from mexico
which is super exciting so my
background's a little bit different
today okay so this is powered by icon
plus capsule the vc firm sponsored by
blockfi luno and we're gonna jump
straight into this because i have a
really really exciting guest today so
she's a best-selling author
the ceo of invest diva which maybe gives
it away a little bit she's been featured
in forbes time cnn it is kiana
daniel kiana how are you
i am doing well how are you
i'm good thank you it's so great to meet
you i've been following you for a really
long time and i absolutely love the work
that you do it's absolutely brilliant
super excited to be on
so for those that don't know you because
i know you're predominantly in the
traditional financial space obviously
you're involved in crypto as well but
obviously i have quite a more of a
crypto audience so for those that don't
know you please can you just give us a
background and tell us what you do
yeah so basically the invest eva
movement's goal is to help
parents actually take control of their
financial future and it is interesting
that i got into cryptocurrency because
they were they asked me to write this
book cryptocurrency for dummies and then
i became at least in the eyes of the
media the crypto lady
but actually what we do is a little bit
much much much deeper we talk about
personal finance
wealth creation like actually creating
this ecosystem of wealth where you're
making more money and then your money is
making more money and
um through ownership and then investing
and then diversifying obviously with
crypto and stocks and whatever assets
that are suitable to you and your
tolerance
so that is what the investiva movement
is actually about it's not just crypto
although i love crypto it's one of
not the biggest but it's a very big
portion of my portfolio
so really just financial liberty just
getting to the crux of it how to build
long lasting wealth
how to build generational wealth is our
goal so how do we compound our compound
faster because of course if you're just
investing you're you're compounding but
it's not fast enough so if you are just
investing 50 bucks per month you get two
million dollars in 65 years which is
great but it's not fast we want to make
money fast and then you want to do it
without it being an mlm or a ponzi
scheme so
basically
i did it and i'm like oh my gosh this
actually works and now i teach how to do
that to other people
so before we get into all of that and
understanding exactly how you build that
generational wealth fast not like an mlm
but fast and in a good way i'd love to
know a little bit more about you you're
are you iranian or your parents are from
iran what's your backstory
yeah so i'm fully iranian persian if you
want to be classy about it and not like
fully virgin jewish
i want to raise actually i was there
until i was 18
and then i went to japan i was there for
seven years and i actually just came to
america 10 years ago so english
i mispronounced something
please don't hate on me the other day i
must pronounce the states american state
and like i got so much hit i'm like oh
my gosh it's just one word so it was my
third language
this play oh i didn't realize that i
didn't realize like you'd only just gone
to the states 10 years ago that's i
didn't know that so how how is it
different than you know when it comes to
finance as a woman
building you know this kind of this
intellect and this knowledge
and these skill sets how is that
different did you struggle in iran with
that
so
both in iran and japan money as a taboo
topic and i've realized also it is in
every other part of the world really in
america a little bit less getting better
but
money is just
a topic you don't want to talk about you
want to pretend that you don't care
about money
and so that's that was my upbringing i
had this what i call the welfare diva
money mindset that you don't want to
talk about money you don't want to even
work for money money doesn't buy your
happiness so that was the mindset
and in japan it was a huge and i got a
little bit
um uh bold with it and i was like
talking about money and importance of
money actually in japan when i was on a
tv show in japan and people are like oh
my god who's this girl
you want well
i was like like they called me like the
bombastic bomb girl or something like
that they gave me this nickname because
i'm like iranian girl talking about
money but um
and it has been i've been trying to get
my money mindset right
it has been a work in progress it wasn't
like coming to america and bam i got my
my survive it wasn't i i came to america
i started working on wall street thought
i hadn't had it all and then i lost
everything again i was about like i
actually lived in a welfare house and
it was um it was tough times and then
again rebuilding and rebuilding and
rebuilding this idea of actually
what money really is and how it can help
you and other people and your children
your grandchildren so
um america has been great in a sense
that um
i feel like it is okay to stand out
so in japan it is not okay to stand out
like they will like literally
not let you stand out
um and they it's very different culture
so america is great in that sense
um what was shocking to me
was that both america and japan
had this male female
wheels
which is surprising because you would
think that iran which is like the
oppressive
country
would be very very hard on women
but i grew up not thinking that math
or anything stem is like well okay
and um
i i went on engineering school without
even even though i wasn't really good at
math because it was like okay it was
like it's going taking history in
college it wasn't like something like a
big deal and then i went to japan i was
the only girl in my class like what
where are the other girls and then i
went to on wall street i'm the only girl
in the team like what so then i was like
wow the culture about this
there was a male dominated field culture
here which was very very interesting
that is really interesting that you
wouldn't know that coming from iran
because a lot of the time the media sort
of portrays a certain picture which
isn't necessarily true and you often
hear you know people living in those
countries that sort of say well actually
that's not how it is um so that's
interesting so you were building a lot
um struggled a little bit but building a
lot so how did you then stumble across
money and wanting to build something and
you know how did you become financially
litter basically
so the journey began in 2008 when the
markets crashed and i was a struggling
engineer trying to find a job and
i'm i really wasn't good at it so um but
i had i was on this tv show that i would
talk about like
social issues and stuff like that and um
on the tv show i learned that the
markets are crashing i had no idea what
the markets are i didn't know what
crashing financial crisis even mean but
they said hey okay so the markets are
crashing
that means the fed is printing money
that means all the i mean all the
central banks have affected i mean also
the japanese central bank and that means
that there's inflation it was like
what's inflation they're like okay that
means that the value of your cash is
going down
and the way to compound and combat it is
to invest it i'm like wow that's cool
and then
that's really cool i accidentally got
into the forex market because i
understood like the exchange rates
because i was in japan i had a japanese
yen i have like i was from so as a
foreigner i understood
what foreign exchange means
yeah
friends is like hey yeah you can like
make money
on this u.s dollar downfall like wow
okay so again accidentally i made like
10 thousand bucks in a month
this is so cool
and yeah that's where it really ignited
that passionate need to understand what
it's all about and it got me to come to
wall street and learning more about it
and then the rest is history
i totally understand the idea of living
in a foreign country and then realizing
how fx works i was living in malta
they used the euro and i was getting
paid in pounds and i was getting paid in
euros and i was like oh i've just made
money now just because of the fx rate
and that also was quite interesting for
me as well so yeah you really have to be
there um to
i guess to trigger to trigger that sort
of like emotional kind of interest in it
um so generational wealth that is
something that we all want if you could
give us you know three tips
i know that's hard i know it's a little
bit unfair you can give us five if you
want to give us five but one like the
main tips to building generational
wealth
so i mean the thing is it's the cliche
it really is it is it's the cliche
so what has worked for me
i call this the zen wealth generator
and it has actually three points point
number one
invest in yourself so that you can
increase your income
two
increase your income so have multiple
revenue streams and point number three
invest the money that you made so invest
in yourself increase your income and
invest in the financial markets and so
what what a lot of people just don't get
is that okay they only want to get like
increase their income or
they only want to become entrepreneurs
so they go and become introverted and
then the stats are
shocking that
um
oh my gosh what was this um 90
of ceos are
three paychecks away from going bankrupt
it's like crazy wow that is crazy
uh i'll don't quote me on the exact
number but it's like a crazy stats and
then you have day traders and investors
who are doing okay but again it's not
fast enough and then day traders again
so they traders they lose money i don't
know if you agree with that but they do
i did it doesn't work
it's not like
the time that you invest
in day trading
in my opinion it absolutely is not worth
the return
because you have to be stuck to your
screen all day and you have to like be
just chasing the speculations all the
things
for me what really really worked
was creating a business
that
works
and creating multiple revenue streams
from there so i have like multiple books
i make money through my affiliate
partnerships and then everything builds
upon each other so it's compounding on
that end and then invest that money so
this way you're putting more and more
money into investment accounts
and everything is compounding at this
exponential return so i've given you an
example is that when i was just
investing at the beginning
my investing strategy is pretty good i'm
actually a good investor so like uh
i i started out with 500 bucks when i
got fired from my job and
i did
go fire i started with 500 bucks and in
three years i turned that 500 bucks into
50 000
which is a great return it's a great
return but fifty thousand dollars barely
pays for like a down payment of a decent
it doesn't it does not in america
doesn't right so
um and but at that return
if i had putting five hundred thousand
dollars in at that return that would
have been 50 million dollars
right yeah of course i was contributing
to that so i was contributing 500 bucks
per month you contribute and then the
return is crazy and then it compounds
like crazy and then once i figured out
a business that can
generate
passive income it's not on mlm
but it's not a lot yeah it's just like
an online business is like this crazy
thing that
is really working for a lot of people
and then combining that
with investing
is what has really made me stand out so
my entrepreneur peers
they are making money they would make a
million dollars in a year but they're
bankrupt
and then my investing peers they're just
like struggling to like they trade and
like make the money and they're hoping
for bitcoin to go up and it's all great
but it's not like happening fast enough
whereas for me i made my first million
through my business
less than a year ago i just want to show
you like how crazy fast it suddenly
became i started out 10 years ago then
less than a year ago i made my first
million
net that was gross profit and the net
profit was probably like 500 bucks
less than a year ago and now today my
portfolio
is four million dollars wow
and i like every month i'm like oh my
gosh this is crazy this is january my
portfolio was like a million and then
march it was like my half and then july
it was 2 million and now it's formally
i'm like oh my gosh the compounding is
just becoming bigger and bigger and like
the impact is just
so like oh my god and and this is and
this is specifically from compound
interest or is this from your business
class is your investing come on business
is making money
and now i have a team of 15 people i'm
spending five thousand dollars per day
on ads like i'm i have expenses
yeah my nerve friends who are in the
same boat
they are either break even or barely
like having some kind of significant
uh portfolio
but for me it has been
crazy compounding not compound ingress
i'm investing in cryptocurrencies i'm
investing in stock market like all the
things like i get all the money that i
make for my business and i dump it in
the in my portfolio with my strategy
and it's just compounding like crazy
so so in terms of the traditional stock
market
sorry about that
something in my throat here so in times
of the traditional stock market
how do you pick your stocks then
so it's actually so i've made it simpler
and simpler simpler over time
because um i used to um you know
it's hard to
it's hard
if you are
paying attention to the media
yes
so when it comes to investing actually
when it comes to anything simplifying is
key
so once i
switched from trying to find the next
best thing
to investing in what i actually know
first of all my emotions were like i
became more sane i stopped checking my
boyfriend seconds
i stopped listening to the news i'm on
the news but i don't listen to the news
which is weird
and then uh it has helped immensely so
how i choose my stocks
uh my portfolio has about 200 shares
which is great stocks which is crazy but
my main my main like my biggest chunks
are the stuff that i personally use and
spend the most money on like the
companies that i spend the most money on
says like superior go to go to my credit
card like okay what are the companies
that i spend the most money on of course
facebook because i spend like five
thousand dollars for diana
no matter like where you stand with them
like oh my gosh is this good is it bad
but for me
i'm like so facebook's not the best
example because i also don't like how
they are controlling people but
i spend a lot of money and i have power
um and like amazon whatever that is
you're you're spending money money like
my husband is a gamer so he spends money
on nvidia and amd and stuff like that so
and we have tesla and like all all the
things that i'm actually a customer of
those are my biggest chunks
and then from there
uh because i have a mastermind and our
inner circle so we mastermind what are
my students
familiar with and we talk about their
experience with the companies so
um that is like the layers and then i
get excited about what they're excited
about that's why i have like 200
different stocks in my portfolio which
is not recommended uh but it's been
working out well for us because then
when the market gets choppy you don't
get
super emotional and make it that mistake
right
so it's literally where you actually see
value where you spend your money
so in terms of
you mention you know emotions
take me through some of the biggest
mistakes people make when it comes to
investing oh my gosh so listening to the
nose is the biggest one
uh falling for the hypo fomo and it's
you can't help it unless you're like
super secure and that's why that's why
like people don't understand the
importance of being confident in your
choice
until
s-h-i-t hits the fan because then you're
like oh my gosh what's happening oh my
gosh
going under what's gonna happen to bite
you what's gonna happen to baba and then
it's very hard and that's why
that's the reason why investing is risky
is because emotions
are very easy to get you
and and you also buy because of emotions
like today again like
forbes contacts me i was like hey
bitcoin reached five fifty five thousand
dollars where do you say i'm like of
course well there's a bullish ticket
and people get more excited and that's
the mo that's why the markets go up and
then it's very hard to not go and buy so
yeah the mistake by far is falling for a
higher fomo and not having a strategy so
i combine
the well knowing what i'm investing in
with
market sentiment analysis
and um i really just it once a month i
don't really
look at the markets i don't go
i don't manage my portfolio based on
what's happening in the news i manage my
portfolio every second wednesday of the
month and that's it like that's my
schedule i don't care what's happening
in the world
so clearly you have this um traditional
financial background you know you spoke
about wall street but what about crypto
then so where did that come in how did
that come into your life so interesting
so
i actually heard about bitcoin in 2011
and one of my friends said hey baby
family there's no way i'm gonna buy
bitcoin
and um completely forgot about it
and it's so
funny that crypto actually just fell on
my laps because first
in 2015 a company in the uk asked me to
start creating crypto content for them
use btc and i was like i don't know
anything about it i'm like
just do it you know about forex and
about stocks you probably can figure it
out i'm like all right so i started
learning about it i was like oh my gosh
this is so cool
that's the first time i really
understood the power of bitcoin like
decentralization all these things
and then
it kind of brought home some
painful things from my past bitcoin so
again being from iran so a little
backstory is my dad
before the iranian revolution at 1979
that many people may not even remember
anymore my dad was actually successful
very a wealthy person
and then
once the revolution came in 1979 this is
before i was born the new islamic regime
took over all of us assets
froze his bank accounts they were going
to kill him
all the stuff they didn't kill him but
they basically took away everything
and when i learned about the
decentralization of business oh my gosh
if you had bitcoin
yeah the government couldn't freeze this
bitcoin like there is no way the
government can access it
and that is that like really hit home
for me
it was okay so this is something that i
want to get more into and then because i
was creating content for news btc and
then i was also getting content for
crypto briefing
then
the four dummies
while these four gummies asked me to
write the book for them right all right
so it kind of fell on my laps
uh that was i would say it was kind of
lucky that i got into it very lucky for
sure and i've become a fan and an
investor in the field ever since
it's still the same idea again isn't it
you have to be personally affected by
something in order to
really um understand it um i find that
really fascinating for me i totally
agree with you that is what struck me
about bitcoin the fact that it's immune
from a government control corruption you
know whatever it is and you know you're
truly suffering of your assets if one
day tyranny comes um so
it makes sense so does that mean that
you are bitcoin only or because this
space can be very tribal you know people
get very emotional about these things so
are you bitcoin only or um tell me what
else do you hold what else do you see
value in i'm not bitcoin only so i treat
my crypto portfolio the way i treat my
soft portfolio i believe in
diversification i'm a value investor at
heart i know value investing is warren
buffett's thing and i understand that
warren buffett is not into crypto but i
think it's just because he's too old and
i think it's good because he doesn't
understand he shouldn't get into it but
i apply his
method
to crypto
so i do
diversify i
again so it's a little bit harder with
crypto because you cannot like become a
cust
consumer or customer
of ethereum like yeah you can get into
the thing i mean i don't want to become
a goal like getting to their networks
and start mining and become a network
but i try to understand as much as
possible about their methodology
and so how i
um
diversify my crypto portfolio is
actually category based because
obviously there are different
cryptocurrency assets for different
purposes
optimize for
payments optimize for platform optimize
for privacy onto optimize for whatever
and then so um and then i
kind of
pick the category king of that category
as my crypto of choice
so bitcoin for me is gold 2.0 so instead
of investing in gold i invest in bitcoin
and then
you know i invest in ethereum i do
invest in cardano and the way i learned
about them well it was again i was
fortunate enough to be able to actually
interview
uh charles huskinson an interview like
the people who are really really
familiar with the different uh crypto
projects
i'm gonna get a little bit hated but um
but i did interview who's this who is
the founder of bitcoin cash i forgot he
used to live in japan oh roger that yeah
great guy we have a lot of smoking with
him he's great yeah he's a great guy a
lot in common lives in japan we bond
over
partying with punky but it kind of made
me not want to actually invest in
between cash so uh
i'm gonna head here but um
that that's how i really
went around the fact so with stocks is
easier because you can't actually go and
become a consumer but with crypto you
actually have to go and learn and so the
learning curve is a little bit harder so
not bitcoin is there
is there a particular coin you're
specifically bullish on so bitcoin2 is
gold 2.0 but a lot of people talk about
ethereum being um internet 2.0 um so how
do you is there anything you're
particularly bullish on right now yeah
so i'm sorry i certainly have ethereum
cordano
um
my boy bitchboy uh kind of talked me to
abe
um but some of the
the the cryptocurrencies that i like
their
mission
are
chain link
and uh yes the channeling is the one
that i actually really like their
mission
and actually i haven't checked my crypto
portfolio but these are the few
like which one which others are but
these are the few that um i've been
investing in
i use it i'd love to get your uh yeah
say that again
xrp
and uh now i just
feel like they have
lost their competitive advantage and so
that's why i'm not as bullish on that
very interesting um
yeah link is what link is one i hold as
well i'm pretty bullish on that i'm very
interested in what's going on with
solana and different ethereum
competitors um so no i i'm totally with
you but i'd love to hear your opinion on
the market right now you know we we've
seen a lot of weird action you know
whether it's
starting with elon musk in the energy
fund when it comes and then china
banning it not banning it banning it not
banning it um pullbacks or 50 but things
seem to be up right now you know um
highest we've been in a long time and
looking at the number now it's about
55.3 k
um so
what's your thoughts on the markets
right now do you think we could
potentially go into new highs or
where you're at oh okay i'm not joking
that i don't listen to the news like i
don't know what's happening
okay so forbes just asked me to comment
on what i see i just looked at the chart
i'm like okay this is what's happening
to me bitcoin has value because bitcoin
has finite amount of bitcoin that can
ever be like to me it's like no-brainers
like supply and demand there's
limited supply and no matter
if china is going to ban it or not ban
it or whatever is going to happen
bitcoin is gonna have value it has a
brand recognition i think it takes all
the points for me so i don't care what
china is doing i don't care what my says
uh but i mean from a technical point of
view obviously bitcoin because it's a
very valid volatile asset uh it looks
like uh it has it definitely has broken
above the hmfa cloud which is an
indicator that i look at has completed a
double bottom chart pattern we have
bullish signs but it also has exhausted
the most recent bullish um
sentiment in the past four days and so
we could see a little bit of a pullback
towards either 52 or 48 and then yeah we
we are in a new bullish cycle so i
wouldn't be surprised if we see 58 and
65 and beyond
uh being reached
and uh okay well
yeah i mean i think it's great that you
don't listen to the news um because you
know it results in a lot of panic
selling and a lot of fun and a lot of
concern um but no i'm also very excited
to see what happens i'm also quite
hopeful and um quite bullish on the fact
that we could actually get back up to 60
um before the end of q4 um
because i was hoping to make enough
money this order to invest even more at
lower prices in bitcoin and then it went
up before i would i got to invest at
lower prices like ah darn it because
there is no doubt in my mind that
bitcoin is going to reach 100k
but i was really reach 100k like three
years so i can invest more
but um yeah i just created hype by
saying that and it's probably
it's not gonna happen so
i think that's what we all want we all
want you know enough time to keep
stacking and keep buying more bitcoin
but you know i don't think he can ever
hold enough bitcoin that's sort of the
way i look at it um but you know
financial literacy is obviously very
very important um
you know just building that long-lasting
generational wealth um but unfortunately
it's not taught in schools um i do
believe we would see a very different
reality if it was taught in school so
you know do you have any thoughts on why
it isn't taught in schools and do you
think one day it might be
it is not taught in any schools anywhere
in the world as far as i'm concerned
it's not taught in iran it's not in
japan and it is clearly not taught in
the u.s there's
really a lot of different reasons
as to why it probably isn't i'm not
actually going to get into it
but um
i'm very
pleased to see that people thanks to the
internet
people are seeing the value of becoming
financially literate i feel like they're
more financially literate people now
than ever before in the past decades
and i'm very very pleased to see that
and people are seeing the value of
self-education and that yeah for
whatever reason they don't teach these
things at school and uh it all also
it comes back to having your own
business and multiple revenue streams so
all right you know what i know it they
want you to become the workers they want
to have the workers and that's what they
don't teach you about entrepreneurship
the teacher about financial literacy
uh they show you this thing and care
things like hey go
get go to college and in college don't
teach all the things so everything that
i know today all the money that i've
ever made
is thanks to self-education so that's
why i mean here i have like the two
comical award i don't know if you guys
can see it i remember i had my
electrical engineering master's degree
over here and i removed it because it
never made me any money and then
self-education
me all this money and so
yeah
educate yourself people
it's funny as well because like it's
free generally speaking or it's not that
expensive you know youtube is free um
you know this conversation we're having
is free um so but yeah it is about
creating workers um like i said we'd
have a very very different um
society you know um
but you you're also not just about you
know having that money mindset but also
about um just a growth mindset in terms
of like positivity and things like that
so how do you stay motivated
how do i say motivated so um well again
so i'm i feel like i am oh i am positive
but i'm also depressed at times so let
me see
so mind blown
yeah wait i'll just stay on that point i
just want to say on that point though
i think every
obviously i just wanted to say i think
every single person who has a growth
mindset replies with that exact response
which i thought was very funny but go on
sorry that's funny i didn't know that
but for me my epiphany
on how to really monitor my emotions
came after watching the secret so that
was my very first
you know being mindful of my emotions
and like going after like actually i
didn't know that like always because my
mom was like a warrior she was always
worrying and like always imagining the
worst case scenario and i thought that's
the way to live
and then i watched the scene i was like
oh my gosh like my mom is literally just
like attracting all the stress and
negativity and the illnesses that was
coming our way
and uh so if somebody doesn't know that
they they will like use their
imagination to to that and so that was
the very first thing that opened my eyes
into the importance of
regulating your mind and what you're
imagining
and then from there i have it has been a
work in progress i have had coaches i've
hired mindset coaches and the more i
invest in myself the more i journal the
more i
do my gratitude and all the things it
actually does help so there are times
that i'm unmotivated or demotivated
which with the right word is or feeling
like a failure or feeling like okay well
so now what okay i accomplished this now
why or what is it even for so you can
you can get go down that rabbit hole and
then for me
um it has been like you know having
coaches or reading a book that or you
know sometimes like even
it's an instagram post was like oh yeah
okay i have to get back to that so
it is all available to us for free which
is just super
crazy
just surrounding yourself then with the
correct information having that healthy
relationship with social media um no i'm
totally with you i'm also very much
about keeping my social media clean and
making sure that i only have good
healthy things coming through
um but you've also grown an amazing
audience on tick tock um which is
absolutely incredible so well done you
know huge congrats it your your views
and your content is so brilliant um but
you i watched a video of yours which
really struck me um i thought it was
really funny and i i want to ask you
about it so you said that um
you've done everything that you wanted
with your career obviously there's
always more to do but you were sort of
happy at a point and then you said now i
want to look for a husband and you said
i'm going to give myself three months to
manifest a husband and then you were
like
and i did it i have to ask you about
this can you tell me why
oh man oh yeah you watched that six
times yeah so i guess
on that one uh yeah it's true i'm i like
these are all the secret like right so i
um
so
okay i got fired from my job and my
boyfriend at the time dumped me and then
i didn't have money to pay rent so i
went that i went back
down that rock bottom and then i
switched my mindset again
and then i started working now one thing
at the time like okay i'm gonna become
an entrepreneur i'm gonna like write a
book i'm gonna do all these things and
then i was like okay i'm too hard-broken
to actually go back on the dating scenes
i'm just going to focus on
this one element and i promise myself
i'm not going to go on a date while i'm
doing it and then once the book was
published my first book we're talking
about um
i was like okay now i'm going to go on
dates all right now i have a husband and
then it's just the same principle
applied to relationships so i had this
jingle that i had written about exactly
who i wanted to be i like what
personality how i wanted to make me feel
uh clearly i didn't think about all the
negative stuff which then came
like when you get married you know but
um all the so when he appeared
and then so it's not about just visual
thinking obviously you have to take
actions i took action i went on 400
dates in three months
um
yeah 400 days in three months 400 first
dates so for 400
uh
coffee dates i was last dates yeah yeah
yeah so and then so i got to meet a lot
of people it's just a numbers game
day and then clarity who we want to meet
and then not giving up right so a lot of
people go on one day and they're like oh
my gosh it was so exhausting and the guy
was this and then they start focusing on
how shitty i'm sorry i just cursed but
that the date was and then to get
motivated to go on a date again
but i just tried to look at the positive
and like okay this is not working okay
you suck at a husband as a husband but
you have this network so tell me about
your network right
let's do business instead
so that was the game plan and then
it was funny because when my husband
showed up now husband showed up i was
not interested in meeting him i did not
like his profile on tinder oh i wasn't
in there by the way i did not like
okay who's this loser who's coming from
connecticut to meet me in new york city
i'm like okay whatever i'll meet with
you i don't have any other dates on that
day i didn't even put on makeup
and then
it's funny because in person you
actually look better
and then when we got into conversation
oh gosh like he's super cool and then
yeah
we got engaged we could spend six months
and then we got marian married
within nine months it's been seven years
now
wow i love that story it's really the
one which struck me i've seen
practically all of your tech talks um
but that's the one that really
the one that stayed with me
and then my husband is my biggest
accomplishment come on
no it's great i think it's lovely no i
think it's wonderful why not i think i
think it's great um
so i also want to talk about like time
management um because you know you do so
much you have a family you're working
you're writing books um which you know
we can talk about but how do you manage
all of that
so
um okay
some things gotta give at some time at
some point so um either money or time
right so when i didn't have money to
spend on
getting back my time
yeah i was not working on my
relationship i was
not even ready to have a baby
um
so
you so what i've noticed what i've
learned is the power of no i learned
this from marie forleo
and it's super important like
understanding what is the one thing so
what is your goal so have clear goals
and then
think about what is the thing what are
the things
that are going to move the needle the
most towards your goal
and then get rid of everything else as
appealing as they sound
and as you grow as my business grows
like these decisions are becoming more
and more like they're not going away
like before i have to make a decision
between like okay like my daughter my
husband and
my business i'll in my portfolio but now
my business has all these arms i have 15
people to manage and i have all these
opportunities i have to go to the on
this interview on that interview listen
like all these things all these shiny
objects
that
uh i sometimes get excited and it's
funny because it actually literally just
happened last week um i i went to fun
hike a lot i don't know if people know
about it and it was it's not an
entrepreneurship event and i was a
speaker there and
then you get to match my with all these
people and get excited about all these
new things that you can do if you have a
software you can have this and you can
have that
all these things and i caught myself and
just getting over overly excited and
wanting to do all these things and then
i started okay
like
it's time to delegate or get rid of
stuff so how i manage my money my time
at this point is
really identifying the one the things
that as i said move the needle towards
my goal whether it's for my business or
for my relationship
uh or with like time with my with my
daughter so
um what are the things that i can do
that are the most important and then get
rid of everything else
so
yeah okay the relationship example now
because i talked about business quite
well so i noticed so when i was really
focused on my business i was neglecting
my relationship with my husband and then
once
um i achieved the goal that i had in my
mind which was like making a million
dollars i was like okay now it's time to
focus on the relationship and then i
invested in a coach in a relationship
coach
and we've been taking the class and now
we're like okay we have we have to have
a date night every week so no matter
what happens like that is the one thing
that i am no matter what happens gonna
make time for
um so
and then i it makes the decision making
easier than whatever that happens on
that day i'll just say no to right so
okay so it's a roller coaster so it's so
so so so really it's like a roller
coaster and
it's prioritizing whatever your priority
is and sometimes you have to say no and
like you said you you know you've got
employees now so it's not just you
running the business um but you've
written a bunch of books so can you tell
me about these books um tell the
audience about the books and you know
what they can expect from them
yeah absolutely so the books that i'm
the most proud of are actually just two
i mean i've written five books but the
ones that i think everybody needs to
read one is cryptocurrency listing for
dummies so
i should i think everybody needs to read
it i think i did a wrong job on that one
because i break down not just
cryptocurrencies but like really the
strategy behind creating portfolio with
crypto and if you want to hit with other
things and
um i really spill everything in that
book and then the second one is a book
that hasn't been published yet it's this
one
and so we actually did a soft launch i
felt like a live that last week um and
this one i talk about the generation
involved which is like not just
investing in but just but also
entrepreneurship this one is going to
get launched in january so get excited
that is very exciting so yeah in january
where can people buy it
so january 9th
this is gonna go live everywhere
so stay tuned we're gonna so
yeah so amazon bookshops just everywhere
yeah barnes noble amazon all the place
all over
and remind us what what's it called i
can't fully read it what does it say
it's called million dollar family
secrets uh it is not published yet so
don't go looking for it it's not there's
no place to be found but it's an actual
book million dollar family secrets
how i it's a great cover i love it
yeah thank you
oh
um fun fact i wrote this book in two
days
two days wow how did you do that how did
you how did you do that
that was like we came up
so we knew that i wanted to write the
book but then the fun like live speaking
opportunity came along was like i really
want to give the book as a gift to the
10 000 audience
and
we it was a month before the
the event
and it was like okay how are we going to
make this happen
and i called one of the publishers that
my ceo recommended and she's like it's
not going to happen you cannot publish a
book in a month
especially when you don't have anything
and then i'm like okay what i can't do
tell me how
so that's a very key question how can we
make it happen okay first of all go
um
call the publishing printer and see how
long they need for it to be published
and shipped
to florida so we call them this okay we
need three weeks i'm like okay so we
need three weeks so that means that
gives us just one week and then the
editor is like okay i need a week to
edit it that means you need to give this
to me on monday we are on the phone on
friday
okay
and so i mean it is a little bit
misleading because i already had the
content in mind i knew exactly what i
was going to talk about
i have
you know this is basically one of my
courses
so we had the content so when i say i
wrote in two books two weeks like it it
didn't just like hey let's come up with
a concept i knew exactly what's going to
be
a four but um like putting it together
and making it into a readable actual
book that gives you results um
that was two days
that's impressive um and i think i think
you actually did that in the smartest
way possible take what you already have
and if you have as a course and you have
these ideas in your head and you know
put it down on paper and sell something
else get that passive income um i think
that's great i can't wait to read it so
i will be keeping my eyes open for
january um so where can people follow
you um you know just just plug yourself
at this point oh plug in so my
i don't have any followers almost on
twitter so please follow me on twitter
but uh
yeah i'm on tick tock at kiana danielle
there are a lot of impersonators there
so please be aware
i'm not verified on tick tock so that
makes it a little bit difficult on
instagram i'm verified so it's at invest
diva
and you know what the bus should just go
on our website all the social media is
plugged in there so just go to
investiva.com everything's there
guys please follow kiana she is so
incredible um you know such a breath of
fresh air um you know i think all of
your financial advice is absolutely spot
on i love following all of your content
so i want to thank you so much for
coming on it's been such a pleasure to
have you
thank you so much for having me it was
really fun
absolutely and guys thank you so much
for tuning in and don't forget to join
us again next week for another brilliant
guess bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]